DEEP FROM THE HEART OF TEXAS.
SPEAKING OF WHICH?
BRIAN:  HOME GAME FOR WILL CAIN
AND WE’RE ALSO TALKING HOME FOR
CONGRESSMAN DAN CRENSHAW,
GOP CONGRESSMAN MAKING REAL
IMPACT.
CONGRESSMAN I GET TWO THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, PEOPLE WERE QUICK TO
JUMP DOWN YOUR GOVERNOR’S THROAT
WHEN HE LIFTED THE MASK MANDATE.
18 OTHER STATES HAVE LIFTED THE
MASK MANDATE AND I SENSE
THERE WAS A DEGREE OF GLEE WHEN
YOU GUYS GOT HIT WITH THAT
FREEZE AND YOUR INFRASTRUCTURE
WAS UNPREPARED FOR IT.
DID YOU PICK-UP BOTH THOSE
THINGS?
>> I DID.
THE PEOPLE ARE JEALOUS OF
FREEDOM AND ONE OF THE
UNFORTUNATE REALITIES OF
MODERN AMERICA IS WE’RE SORT OF
DIVIDING INTO FREE STATES VERSUS
NON-FREE STATES, AND AS YOU JUST
INDICATED ON YOUR SHOW, PEOPLE
ARE MOVING WITH THEIR FEET.
THEY WANT TO BE FREE, RIGHT?
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE ENTICED BY
THE DEMOCRATS NOTIONS AND SORT
OF LIP SERVICE TO COMPASSION AND
ARGUMENTS BUT IN THE END THEY
WANT TO PURSUE THEIR HAPPINESS
AS THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE GIVES US THE RIGHT
TO, SO, LOOK.
YOU WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT
TEXAS MADE MASKS ILLEGAL, BASED
ON THE UNHINGED RESPONSE FROM SO
MANY LEFTISTS ON TWITTER TALKING
ABOUT MURDERS AND KILLERS AND
LOOK, YOU’RE SIDING WITH THE
VIRUS.
NO MORE VACCINES FOR TEXAS IS
WHAT THEY SAID.
THIS IS REALLY DISGUSTING AND
IT’S DISGISTING ON A FUNDAMENTAL
LEVEL.
I THINK YOU SHOULD STILL WEAR A
MASK IF YOU CAN’T SOCIALLY
DISTANCE AND YOU’RE NOT
VACCINATED BUT I DON’T WANT TO
FINE OR  JAIL YOU IF YOU DON’T,
RIGHT?
THIS ISN’T THAT HARD OF A
CONCEPT, GUYS.
THERE HAS TO BE A CONTRACT
BETWEEN THE GOVERNED AND
GOVERNMENT, AND THERE HAS TO BE
TRUST INVOLVED AND WHAT WE’VE
LOST OVER THE LAST YEAR AND
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS HAVE NOT BEEN
TOTALLY HONEST WITH US, OUR
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS HAVE MADE
EMOTIONAL DECISIONS INSTEAD OF
LOGICAL ONES AND THAT TRUST HAS
BEEN BROKEN.
LOCKDOWNS DON’T WORK.
THEY DON’T WORK.
THAT’S WHY I INTRODUCED THE
UNLOCK DOWNS NOW ACT BECAUSE
IT’S BASED ON A PREMISE THE
SCIENCE SAYS THERE IS NO CO-
RELATION BETWEEN SLOWING THE
SPREAD AND SHELTER IN PLACE
ORDERS
LOCKING DOWN BUSINESSES, IT
DOESN’T WORK.
IT’S A VIRUS.
IT SPREADS.
IT’S UNFORTUNATE, BUT IT DOES,
AND I THINK DEMOCRATS NEED TO
LISTEN TO THE SCIENCE, LISTEN TO
THE DATA, AND ACTUALLY ABSORB
THAT INFORMATION AND STOP
HURTING PEOPLE.
STEVE: WELL LOCKDOWNS DON’T WORK
, EXCEPT AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, AND THEY SEEM TO WORK
DURING THE TRUMP YEARS, BUT NOW
WITH JOE BIDEN, YOU KNOW, THERE
IS THIS GIGANTIC SURGE.
THEY WON’T CALL IT, THEY CALL IT
A CHALLENGE, BUT CONGRESSMAN, I
THINK, YOU KNOW, THE MESSAGING
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE RIGHT NOW
IS DON’T COME NOW.
I THINK THEY WANT THEM TO COME
NOW, BECAUSE IT’S MESSY, BUT
ULTIMATELY, IT’S GOING TO GET
THINGS GOING SO THAT THEY
CAN GET TO WHAT THEY WANT WHICH
IS, AS PEOPLE IN YOUR PARTY SAY,
OPEN BORDERS.
>> YEAH, LOOK.
I’M DONE TRYING TO READ THEIR
INTENTIONS ANY OTHER WAY.
IT’S VERY VERY CONCERNING.
EVERY STEP OF THE DEMOCRAT’S
TAKE WHETHER IN LEGISLATION OR
IN THIS ADMINISTRATION IS MEANT
TO HAVE MORE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
, SO WE WANT
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THINGS HERE
, AND THIS IS A VERY SHARP
LEFT TURN FOR THE DEMOCRAT
PARTIES OVER THE LAST 10 YEARS.
IT’S VERY UNFORTUNATE.
LOOK, THERE IS A CRISIS ON THE
BORDER.
NOW, BIDEN MAY NOT ACTUALLY LIKE
THAT.
THEY MIGHT WANT A MORE STEADY,
EVEN-HANDED FLOW OVER THE NEXT
FEW YEARS, BUT THERE’S A CRISIS.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE I WAS JUST
DOWN THERE LAST WEEKEND, OUR
BORDER PATROL IS OVERWHELMED,
AND THE FACT THAT THEY’RE
OVERWHELMED PROCESSING PEOPLE,
BEING BUS DRIVERS BEING DAYCARE
WORKERS GUESS WHO FOOTS THE BILL
FOR THIS , TEXANS.
TEXAS DPS SPENDS HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A YEAR
TRYING TO SECURE OUR BORDER
BECAUSE WHILE BORDER PATROL IS
TAKEN OFF THE LINE THEY CAN’T
PATROL THE BORDER BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO DEAL WITH HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE BRINGING
THEIR KIDS ACROSS THE RIVER,
WELL THEN TEXAS DPS HAS TO
ACTUALLY PATROL THE RIVER AND
GET IN HELICOPTERS AND PATROL
THERE AND GO AFTER DRUG SMUGGLER
S AND THEY HAD 600
PURSUITS IN JUST ONE AREA OVER
THE COURSE OF LAST YEAR.
THESE ARE REALLY DANGEROUS TIMES
FOR THEM, SO ACTUALLY JUST
INTRODUCED A BILL THAT WOULD PAY
TEXAS A BIPARTISAN BILL BY THE
WAY THAT PAYS TEXAS BACK FOR
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
WE HAVE SPENT ON BORDER
OPERATIONS THAT ARE A FEDERAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
AINSLEY: OH, WOW.
WHAT ARE THE CHANCES OF GETTING
THAT MONEY?
THAT SOUNDS FAIR.
>> IT DOES SOUND FAIR.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE’RE ALREADY SPENDING
1.9 TRILLION ON A BUNCH OF OTHER
NONSENSE, WE’LL BE ADDING SOME
MONEY TO THE BORDER MIGHT BE A
GOOD INVESTMENT.
AINSLEY: I WANT TO ASK YOU WHEN
YOU WENT DOWN TO THE BORDER I
JUST WANT FATHOM LETTING MY
CHILD GO.
I KNOW MAYBE THEY COME TO
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS, ALONE, AND
SO MANY UNACCOMPANIED KIDS.
WHAT ARE THEIR STORIES?
HAVE YOU HEARD ANY OF THOSE
STORIES?
HOW DO THEIR PARENTS ALLOW THEM
TO DO THAT?
I UNDERSTAND THEY KNOW IT’S A
BETTER LIFE IN AMERICA BUT WHAT
ARE YOU HEARING?
>> LOOK IT’S HEARTBREAKING.
WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THE
COMPASSIONATE SIDE OF THIS.
IT ALSO DEMONSTRATES WHAT AN
AMAZING COUNTRY THIS IS, THAT
YOU CAN JUST TELL YOUR CHILD,
YOUR ONLY CHILD, PERHAPS, THAT
IF YOU JUST WALK ACROSS THAT
BORDER YOU’LL PROBABLY BE OKAY
BECAUSE OUR COUNTRY IS THAT GOOD
OKAY, MEGHAN MARKLE IT REALLY IS
THAT GOOD, AND HERE IS THE THING
THEY COME ACROSS, THEY MIGHT
HAVE A COUSIN, THEY MIGHT HAVE
AN UNCLE, OFTENTIMES THEY MIGHT
HAVE SOMEBODY THAT THEY THINK
WILL SPONSOR THEM, A FRIEND, OR
SOMETHING ON THE OTHER SIDE BUT
IT’S COMPLETELY OVERWHELMING TO
OUR BORDER PATROL.
THIS IS COMPLETELY UNSUSTAINABLE
WHEN TRUMP WAS GETTING A BUNCH
OF CRAP FOR THE KIDS IN CAGES
THING AND NOW BIDEN IS DOING THE
EXACT SAME THING, LOOK THE
LESSON HERE IS IT’S REALLY
REALLY HARD TO DEAL WITH
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF MINOR
S WHETHER THEY ARE WITH AN
ADULT OR  WHETHER THEY ARE ALONE
, ALL AT ONCE.
IN FACT, IT’S NEAR IMPOSSIBLE TO
DO THIS WELL.
IT’S A COMPLETELY UNSUSTAINABLE
SITUATION.
THE REASON THIS IS HAPPENING IS
BECAUSE BIDEN COMPLETELY
REVERSED THE TRUMP ADMINITRATION
POLICIES OF REMAIN IN MEXICO,
AND THE ASYLUM COOPERATION
AGREEMENTS WITH THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES.
THESE WERE OUR SILVER BULLET.
THESE CREATED A DISINCENTIVE TO
COME BECAUSE WE SAID LOOK, IF
YOU’RE GOING TO CLAIM ASYLUM,
AND ONLY ABOUT 10% OF PEOPLE
MEET THE LEGAL STANDARD FOR
ASYLUM, THEN GO TO THE LOCAL
CONSOLATE.
GO TO THE LOCAL EMBASSY AND WAIT
HERE IN MEXICO, WE WILL
ADJUDICATE YOUR CLAIM, BUT YOU
CAN’T JUST COME IN HERE, GET A
BUS TICKET ANYWHERE, AND THEN,
YOU KNOW, NOT SHOW UP FOR YOUR
DEPORTATION HEARING WHEN IT’S
SHOWN THAT YOUR ASYLUM CLAIM,
YOU KNOW, ISN’T VALID.
THAT’S UNFAIR, AND YOU KNOW WHO
IT’S UNFAIR TO?
LEGAL IMMIGRANTS FOR ONE, AND
IT’S ALSO UNFAIR TO MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD WHO
CAN’T JUST WALK ACROSS THE
BORDER, WHO HAVE TRULY VALID
ASYLUM CLAIMS.
WE’RE CLOGGING UP OUR SYSTEM FOR
PEOPLE WHO REALLY NEED IT
AND IT’S NOT FAIR OR   MORAL.
BRIAN:  WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION REFORM
, IT STARTS WITH BORDER
SECURITY, AND YOU HAD MONEY FOR
THE WALL.
IT WAS ALREADY, ITS ALREADY BEEN
SPENT AND NOW YOU’RE PAYING
PENALTIES KNOW THE TO BUILD IT.
THEN YOU TURN AROUND AND MAKE IT
EASIER MAYBE FOR THESE COUNTRIES
PEOPLE TO GET HERE LEGALLY BUT
YOU’RE SAYING THAT PEOPLE FROM
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES ARE MORE
IMPORTANT THAN PEOPLE FROM
NIGERIA, FROM ZAMBIA, FROM COSTA
RICA, FROM NORWAY, FROM AROUND
THE WORLD.
YOU’RE SAYING THEY’RE MORE
IMPORTANT SO THAT’S WHO, AND
BRAZIL.
THAT’S WHO THIS SHOULD BE ABOUT.
WE COULD ONLY BRING IN SO MANY
PEOPLE.
YOU COULD DO IT LEGALLY OR
ILLEGALLY.
DON’T THINK YOU’RE GOING TO COME
BACK AND TALK TO REPUBLICAN
S ABOUT IMMIGRATION
REFORM WHEN YOU REFUSE TO
ENFORCE THE BORDER.
WE’VE SEEN THIS MOVIE SINCE 1985
>> YEAH, NO THAT’S EXACTLY
RIGHT AND WE HAVE TO FOOT THE
BILL FOR IT AND LOOK IT’S
REVERSIBLE.
THIS IS A COMPLETELY SOLVABLE
PROBLEM.
YOU HAVE TO ACTUALLY --
BRIAN:  WANT TO.
>> THE COOPERATION AGREEMENTS
WITH OUR PARTNERS, WHICH IS
MEXICO, HONDURAS, GUATEMALA, AND
THEY WANT TO WORK WITH US.
BRIAN:  THERE SHOULD BE SOMEBODY
THERE NOW, DAN.
THERE SHOULD BE SOMEBODY THERE
NOW, NEATING WITH ALL THESE
THREE COUNTRIES.
>> YEAH, EXACTLY BUT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DOESN’T WANT TO.
LOOK, THEY HAVE A PLAN IN PLACE,
THEY’VE ALREADY RELEASED IT AND
IT DOES INVOLVE GIVING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS CITIZENSHIP AND
VOTING RIGHTS.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY WANT THEM TO VOTE
FOR THEM.
THAT’S A CYNICAL PROPOSITION BUT
I DON’T KNOW HOW ELSE TO
INTERPRET IT.
I THINK IT’S TRUE.
STEVE: SPEAKING OF VOTING LATER
TODAY THE HOUSE COULD ACTUALLY
VOTE ON THAT $1.9 TRILLION COVID
RELIEF BILL, AND NANCY PELOSI,
I’VE GOT NEWS FOR YOU, MR.
CRENSHAW, SHE CAN SEE
THROUGH WHAT YOU REPUBLICANS
ARE TRYING TO DO.
LISTEN TO THE SOUND BITE AND
THEN WE’LL GET YOUR OPINION.
>> I’M SO EXCITED, I JUST CAN’T
HIDE IT.
ALL OF IT, EXCELLENT.
ALL OF IT FAIR.
ALL OF IT AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO GROW THE ECONOMY BY INVESTING
IN THE PEOPLE FOR THE PEOPLE.
FOR OUR REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
WHO THEY SAY NO TO THE VOTE AND
THEY SHOW UP AT THE RIBBON
CUTTINGS OR  THE PRESENTATION.
STEVE: SO SHE SAYS REPUBLICANS
ARE GOING TO VOTE NO WHEN IT
COUNTS, BUT THEN, YOU KNOW, WHEN
PEOPLE COME OUT AND SEE FOLKS AT
THE RIBBON CUTTING AND THE MALL
OPENING YOU REPUBLICANS ARE
GOING TO TAKE CREDIT FOR ALL
THAT DOUGH.
>> WELL THE THING IS THIS MONEY
ISN’T BEING INVESTED IN YOU, OR
YOUR ECONOMY, AND LOOK, IF
YOU’RE REALLY HAPPY ABOUT
GETTING A $1,400 CHECK, AGAIN,
IMAGINE THAT, RIGHT?
GIVING FREE MONEY TO PEOPLE IS
POPULAR.
I GET THAT BUT HERE IS THE THING
IT’S COSTING YOU $5,700 GIVE OR
TAKE AND IF YOU’RE NOT PAYING
FOR IT, YOUR KIDS ARE.
LOOK IF THIS IS REALLY AS
POPULAR AS THE DEMOCRATS SAY
IT IS WE’RE IN A LOT OF TROUBLE
AS A COUNTRY.
IT MEANS THAT WE HAVE FULLY
GIVEN INTO THIS NOTION THAT WE
SHOULD BE BRIBED BY OUR
GOVERNMENT FOR FALSE PROMISES,
AND THAT IS NOT AN AMERICAN
THING TO DO.
WE HAVE TO COLLECTIVELY STOP
DOING THAT.
IT’S GOING TO DESTROY THE NEXT
GENERATION.
ITS ALREADY THREATENING TO CAUSE
MASSIVE INFLATION.
HERE IS THE OTHER THING ABOUT
THIS BILL.
THERE’S ALREADY TRILLIONS,
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS, ABOUT A
TRILLION DOLLARS OF UNSPENT FROM
PAST RELIEF BILLS.
THERE IS MONEY IN THE  PPP FUND
THAT COULD GO TO SMALL
BUSINESSES IF YOU CHANGE THE
STANDARDS OF HOW THEY GET IT
THAT BE SMART.
HALF OF THIS MONEY WON’T EVEN BE
SPENT UNTIL 2022 OR  LATER.
IT IS AN ABSOLUTE LIE FOR THEM
TO SAY THAT THIS IS AN EMERGENCY
RELIEF BILL THAT GOES AND INVEST
S DIRECTLY INTO PEOPLE.
IT IS FOR A LOT OF DIFFERENT
NONSENSE THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH COVID.
ONLY 9% HAS TO DO WITH COVID
HEALTHCARE AND 1% IS FOR VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION.
THESE PEOPLE ARE JUST LYING AND
WE CAN’T KEEP FALLING FOR IT AS
AMERICANS.
WE CANNOT KEEP BELIEVING THIS
FALSEHOOD THAT THE SIZE OF
YOUR HEART IS ATTACHED TO DOLLAR
SIGNS, RIGHT?
AND WHOEVER IS WILLING TO SPEND
THE MOST MONEY OF YOUR MONEY, BY
THE WAY, IS SOMEHOW MORE MORAL.
THIS IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE.
AINSLEY: I THINK THAT’S WHAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE UPSET WITH.
THEY DON’T MIND THE 9%.
THEY DON’T EVEN MIND THE CHECKS
THAT’S WONDERFUL FOR THE LIVES
OF OTHER PEOPLE BUT IT’S ALL THE
EXTRA PORK THAT’S JUST
THROWN IN THERE AND THEY CAN DO
IT BECAUSE EVERYONE’S GETTING A
CHECK, YOU KNOW?
BRIAN:  WE’RE CONSERVING NATIVE
AMERICAN LANGUAGES IT’S AN
EMERGENCY.
EVERYONE’S FORGETTING THEM FOR
$10 MILLION, WE’LL REMEMBER
THEM.
FANTASTIC.
>> AND LOOK, WE FELL FOR THIS
TOO AS CONSERVATIVES.
I REMEMBER IN DECEMBER, I
REMEMBER A LOT OF PEOPLE WANTING
$2,000 CHECKS BUT IT DOESN’T
MEAN IT’S GOOD POLICY.
THERE IS NO FREE MONEY AND HERE
IS THE THING.
THOSE FREE CHECKS ARE GOING TO
GO TO WELL OVER 100 MILLION
PEOPLE WHO NEVER LOST THEIR JOB
AT ALL AND JUST WORKING FROM
HOME SO IS THIS REALLY WHAT WE
NEED TO BE DOING?
IS THIS REALLY GOOD POLICY?
NO I DON’T THINK IT IS.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT DAN CRENSHAW